Yael Benvenisti, thank you
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm fine, thank you.
Really great to have you here.
I'm gonna learn about aging
in the next 20 minutes.
You're an expert in the longetivity space.
You're actually named
both in 2019 and 2020
one of Israel's top influencers
and experts in the longetivity space.
The CEO of Mediterranean Towers Ventures,
but you're also running a private clinic.
And you mentioned that that's leftovers
from the first degree,
so I'll have to understand
a little bit why.
But Yael, we have to start
with the fun fact
because who doesn't like chocolate? What?
Me. I hate chocolate.
I think I'm unique in that space
but really I cannot eat it.
It's like somebody saying
that they don't like music.
I know,
but really if you want to surprise me,
please do not bring chocolate.
Bring flowers, ...
I love it. Okay.
Yael, first of all,
before we even dive deep
into your personal journey,
give me a little bit of background
as to what is the longetivity space?
What is this thing called Aging2.0
that you're so passionate about?
Okay, well we all know
that the world is getting older.
If we are looking
at what is happening now,
there are around 12% of the population
that are 60 and above.
If we're looking at the year 2030,
there will be 16% of the population
that are 60 and above.
And in the year 2050,
there will be more than 20%.
That means that
every fifth person in the world
is going to be older adult.
And this changes our whole society.
And this opens a huge market
and opportunity for innovation.
And if we, as a society,
want to continue and provide services
to a growing population,
and still we have a limit in our budget,
there's no other solution
than to develop technologies.
So, I think this is the only way
that we should go.
We should really implant technologies
in our services, in our life
in order to have quality of life
and not just live longer.
So you're saying that
in the next dozen years,
we're gonna see that
one in five people in the world
are going to be elderly,
and that's a fantastic case
as to why we need to continue innovating
and put at least, I'm imagining, a fifth
of our innovative efforts
on the elderly population, if not more
because a lot of the times
they need more assistance, right,
than the younger generation.
Yet, if I look at the landscape
of startups and of innovations
that are happening today,
I don't think a fifth of them
are dealing with the longetivity space.
Is that right?
That's right.
It feels like there a shortage.
Yes, because I think
the demographic change
begin just now,
because the baby boomers,
the ones that were born
after World War II,
they are just now entering
what we are called
being older adult.
So we just, I think in the four, three years,
we can see the change that is developing.
And we can see the big companies
are trying to enter the market.
We can see Apple Watch,
that is, it's a senior Apple Watch.
We can see Amazon, we can see Best Buy,
all of them are opening departments
for technologies or products
for the elderly.
We will see the change
this period, the covid-19 period,
had done really big things
with elderly and how we approach elderly.
And this is not only
about being vulnerable
or someone that is being fraud,
it's all about having a good life,
opportunities,
being active in society
and what will happen now
if I have to stay at home
because it's too dangerous outside.
How do I continue my life, my activities.
And technology is the answer.
So Yael, give me
a little bit of background
as to what needs to happen
in the longetivity space.
So, in order for us to accommodate
for the growing elderly population
and to be able to help
improving their lives as well,
what spaces within the longetivity space
do we need to focus on?
Is it health care?
Is it loneliness?
Is it communication?
What do you think?
Well Aging2.0 which is organization,
it's an international organization,
based in San Francisco
but it has, I think,
almost 150 ambassadors
all over the world.
We are the Israeli ambassadors.
They define eight segments in which
we can see technologies for aging well.
The first one is engagement and purpose.
The second one is financial wellness,
mobility and movement,
daily living and lifestyle,
caregiving or care coordination,
brain health and the end of life.
In each segment, we can see
a various of technologies
like virtual reality, augmented reality,
robots, IOT, artificial intelligence,
machine learning.
The type of technology is not important;
it is the space
that they are connected with.
And if we will invest in those area,
we will see individual well-being
and well health.
We can see workforce participation,
because people will be able
to work longer.
We will see a raise in the consumption
because people will buy more things,
so they will continue
and develop the economic of the country.
We will see a lot of innovation
because this is an empty space.
It just begin in these activities.
So by the way, Yael,
out of those eight segments
that you were talking about,
which one are you most attracted to?
Because I could make
a very strong case as to why
you should be passionate
about all of them,
but what really gets you excited?
I think that continue your lifestyle
and daily living
will make the the biggest change
in our life.
So, can you clarify?
Does that mean that people
will not stop living
the way that they are living
just because they're getting older
and they're having more challenges
because of their physiology?
This is exactly what I'm saying.
It doesn't matter
if you cannot leave your home,
if you have some disability;
you will continue your favorite lifestyle,
you will continue to be active
in your community, in your family,
do what you like to do.
Even if you will stay at your home,
that doesn't mean that
you will not have a community
to be engaged in or friends or family
or doing whatever you want.
Learning something new.
Right. But I'm thinking still, Yael,
today. The past 20 years,
we've had such a boom
in consumer technology
and things that are helping us
live our lives better,
yet even my own grandparents, who are 85,
and they have a phone and everything,
there's still no technology
that is helping us communicate better
and is helping ...
between the generation gaps.
You know I'm thinking about
my six year old niece
and my 85 year old grandmother,
they love talking to each other.
And it's getting,
I can just imagine that if they will be
disconnected geographically,
it'll be nearly impossible
to bridge that communication gap.
So why even today isn't there
any practical solutions for these,
because the market is already here?
Well there is,
but there is a lack of knowledge.
There is a lack of knowledge at your side,
as a family member,
and a lack of knowledge
in your grandmother or grandfather side.
So, we are doing what we can
in order to spread the ...
but it's hard.
I personally have a segment
in one of the commercial TV channels,
in one of the morning shows.
So, I'm trying to spread the ...
that there are solutions,
there are wonderful solution,
even for people
that are not technologists at all.
They don't know how to operate Zoom,
they don't know how to push a button,
they don't know how to operate
the WhatsApp video.
There is a technology using the TV screen
or even just using a regular screen
that is not a TV,
that when you schedule in an hour,
the video conversation will be open.
The person just had to sit
in front the screen and that's it.
- I love it
That's all it is.
... and the cost is so low, really.
It cost around one dollar a day.
It's nothing,
but people do not know.
So we have work to do.
Definitely. I actually,
I participated in a hackathon
here in Palo Alto at Y Combinator
a few months ago
with my friends from Stanford.
And we developed this app
where we put a camera on the TV,
and when the grandchild calls
their grandfather a grandmother
on the phone, it shows on their TV.
And then all the elderly person has to do
is wave in front of the camera
and it'll open,
more for the accessibility side,
but we were still shocked
that the number of solutions,
even if a few do exist,
it's still very limited.
But Yael, I'd love to learn
a little bit more
about what you're doing specifically
with Mediterranean Towers Ventures,
and how specifically you got into this.
Because you're very young.
You can be doing anything else
... doing venture capital,
yet you're excited about
the longetivity space,
and I have to really understand why.
Well, it all started years ago.
I was a young physiotherapist
working one of the HMOs.
And my grandma was a resident
in one of the nursing homes
in my hometown.
And one night the staff,
they didn't close the bars
of the beds properly.
And the bars fell down and she rolled over
and she hit her head in the bleacher
that was standing near the bed.
And she died from a brain hemorrhage.
- Oh no
So at that point, I made the decision
that this will never happen again.
I quit my job.
I went to learn rehabilitation
and geriatrics and start working
in rehabilitation centers
and in nursing homes
with elderly people.
And I just loved it.
And I continue looking for solutions
that these sort of things
will never happen again.
And then I joined the society,
the Electrical and Electronic
Engineering Society in Israel.
They opened a new group,
Technologies for Aging Well.
And I was elected as the chairman.
We started 14 people
around one table.
Didn't know what to do.
Now we are more than 1,500 members.
So, we are very proud.
We have a very nice ecosystem.
Very active.
Yes. So, you were elected chairman
to the organization, to the society.
Yes. And we started as 14 people
around one table,
and we really didn't know what to do.
And now, we are more than 1,500 members.
A very active ecosystem.
We are very proud.
We joined Aging2.0
that is international organization.
And two years ago, two and a half years ago,
Mediterranean Towers Venture,
which is a publicly traded company,
they came to one of our conference
and they said that they want to open
a CVC, corporate venture capital,
and invest in technologies for aging well.
Mediterranean Towers Group is a company
that is running
independent living facilities in Israel.
It's the biggest private
independent ... facilities in Israel.
And we opened the fund.
This is the only venture capital in Israel
that invest in this space.
We are very proud.
- Wow.
And we open, even if we don't invest in a company,
we open our facilities for focus group
or for beta testing,
and we try really to give a push
to the whole ecosystem in Israel.
Right. It sounds like it's beyond
just another venture capital firm.
This is, it's a mission driven fund
that is about the community
and about fostering
an innovative community
in the startup nation
to help, also motivate, more people
to create companies in this space.
So, even if you don't invest
you're actually helping them
continue to grow
and develop the relationship with them.
It's not just a financial transaction.
It's much more about a community, right?
Right.
Each year we're doing a competition.
And our judges
is not just a panelist of experts,
it's also our residents.
They get a chance to vote
and they get a chance
to ask the entrepreneurs
all the questions.
And they're really doing a great job.
It's not easy to stand on the stage
and to answer their questions,
because they have very good questions.
And we are very proud
that they really are active and they shape
the next generation of products
for the elderly generation.
So, putting on the investment hat,
are the returns in this space
the same as in other spaces
like cybersecurity
and other consumer technologies?
Like what are the differences
between the longetivity space
and investing exclusively or primarily
in the longetivity space
rather than other funds
that may be focusing on other industries?
Well first of all,
we are focused in the space
and not in the technology.
So, I think we are very young space,
so the number of exits are really small.
But we can see the trend.
We can see that
all these technologies are raising.
When I think two years ago
we saw most of the companies
raising seed money.
Now we can see they passed A-round
and they are continue to developing. Ours,
we made three investments,
all of them are now passed A-rounds.
So, we are very proud.
And it's only two years ago,
so it happens fast.
- Wonderful
We can see the trend.
We can see the really
the potential in this area.
It's like FinTech five years ago.
You have to be patient.
No, no I love it. Yeah.
but it will happen,
definitely it will happen.
So Yael, for myself and for my friends
who are watching this,
we're also considering
what to start their next venture,
and as we know, especially in Israel,
it is very common
out of the intelligence unit
to go more into the cybersecurity spaces
and those types of fields.
But I'd love to hear a few ideas
just to get the juices running
for young entrepreneurs
that are thinking of what to do next.
And I want to understand really
what are the opportunities in this space.
And maybe you can give me
two or three high level ideas of problems
that one can tackle
in the aging and longetivity space
using technology.
Well first of all,
when we are talking about technologies
for aging well,
we are talking about a platform
that will combine several services,
because we cannot put a lot of devices
in your house and use them
at the same time.
It's too complicated,
and it's too expensive.
So you have to build a platform
that will give a service
service,
and the service must solve some need.
Cybersecurity is nice,
but it doesn't solve a problem for me
as an individual.
But as an older adult
that wants to continue
and live his life like he used to do,
it must solve a problem,
some need.
This is a very big difference.
And I think that every entrepreneur
that is entering the space
must think about who is the customer
and who is the payer.
It's not the same person most of the time.
Right. Right.
And it's a little bit complicated.
But if I'm comparing this
to the younger generation,
you must understand that the product
that you are selling
for a three years old child
is not the same product that you will sell
for a 16 years old child.
This is the same
as the older adult population;
you cannot sell the same product
for a 65 years old person
or to a 90 year old person.
This is a huge population,
a lot of segmentation,
inner segmentation, especially
the ability to perform your activity,
how activity you are.
You have to do a good segmentation
of the population
and know who is your customer,
what you are selling,
and who will want to pay for it.
I think that's fascinating.
And I've been thinking quite a bit
about this space,
and one of the things
that really intrigued me is that
this space, more so than a lot of others,
like you said, a lot of times
the person who is using your product
is not necessarily the person
who's buying the product.
So you have almost
like a two sided marketplace
and you have to really understand
who are the moving players in this puzzle.
But it's really, really fascinating.
Yael, so I understand the passion
that you're coming in doing this.
Do you see yourself
staying in this space for a long time?
I know that you also are still practicing
from your original profession
out of a love for that profession,
but do you see yourself continuing
with that mission for many years to come?
Or is this something that you're saying,
I want to make a dent now
and potentially later I'll move on
to different industries?
No, I will say in this industry
it has a huge potential.
I saw more than 250 companies
in three years.
I see the activity.
I have a lot of knowledge today
that I didn't have four years ago.
I want to give it to our entrepreneurs
and really to put Israel
as the leading country
for AgeTech in the world.
I love it. Okay,
and on that note Yael,
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself,
and I need you to explain
a little bit about these words.
Well, I'm a perfectionist person.
I love perfection, really.
I have to learn about everything
and to understand it
until I make a decision.
I live a good life, really.
I'm having a good life.
I love coming to my work.
I'm coming every day with passion,
I see a lot of new things,
and I feel that I can contribute
to the space.
And the last word is a blonde
... the color.
I'm not a neutral tone.
I love it.
Yes.
And it's really fun because
when people see me,
they know my degree,
that I have a PhD in geriatrics,
and when I come to a conference
or to a meeting, they say,
"Wow. You?"
I said,
"Yes. I'm shaping my future.
I'm doing it for me.
My future will look different"
Well your future,
but it sounds like you're also
in the process of helping millions
if not billions of others down the line.
So, shaping your future while shaping
everybody else's future as well.
Yael, thank you very, very much
for the inspiration.
This was wonderful.
I'm personally very passionate
about this space that you're in,
and that's why I was so excited
when you agreed to do
this episode with me.
And I hope that I'll definitely take
an active part in this space,
and I hope that my friends,
both at Stanford and 8200,
will also consider this as a viable path
in their entrepreneurship journey.
And thank you for all the insights
over the past 20 minutes.
Thank you.
Take care.
Bye.